Thank the Lord for all of you.
Right? Thank the Lord for all of you.
My support hasn't dropped.
This is how I gauge whether the Lord
wants me to do this and do it without
fear of having to answer to powers that
be and kiss butt so I can be part of a
clique.
So glory to God, I saw pay PayPal and
you know this is miraculous work of the
Lord. I don't have large numbers, you
see. I'm now down to 200s, less than
300, less than 400.
But because God is good, he stirs up
people behind the scenes who are
watching
and they are contributing. Pray if this
is what God wants me to do, my support
doesn't drop because if it drops,
I will not process it to myself. God
forbid me, save me from that. I'll find
something else to do.
The reason why I say thank the Lord for
the support because then I can call out
these pigs.
Go to my YouTube section, check the
post.
Your heart will be broken
at what is happening to Christians.
SOMEONE WAS COMPLAINING, "WHY DON'T YOU
TALK ABOUT what's happening in Nigeria?"
Who said I haven't? Or Pakistan, you
lying, slandering dog, I do.
But the number one topic now
is United States of Israel doing the
bidding of Netanyahu to fight
Netanyahu's wars, sending our sons and
daughters to wars, getting them
finding some billions while they are
persecuting Christians,
attacking Christians, bombing Christians
in their churches, and desecrating their
images.
You see why
I have to speak?
Because among the apologists, who's
addressing this?
In point of fact, it's the opposite.
What you have is Deborah Woodstein, an
adulterous prophet, these dogs of Zion.
And I got to be careful because his
minions flagged me.
Your minions, your cult followers,
they are chilling for Israel.
Not a peep about what's happening
to the Christians of Lebanon.
And by the way, I'm not just concerned
about Christians.
If you really love Jesus Christ,
then innocent non-Christians should
break your heart when they're being
bombed and blown to smithereens.
I would like to play some of these
clips, but I can't because that video
that I uploaded with the Israeli
man
violently shoved the nun and he kicked
her.
I found footage where he kicked her as
she was lying down.
He kicked her.
YouTube said that they restricted the
video so that under 18 can't watch it.
So, I got to be careful.
But, I gave you the links. He kicked her
while she was down.
Here it is.
He kicked her, guys.
If I'm invited, Grams I'll come to your
church and do core doctrines for the
church. Catholics, Orthodox,
Assyrian church, I'll go to all your
churches, right? Even though I'm with
the Catholic church, I'll come to your
churches and talk about the things we
agree.
Right?
He kicked her, guys.
And then I have a video of a I believe a
Korean lady in Israel several times spit
on, hit, and beat.
She got hit physically in the face and
she was crying.
All right?
Are you aware that they bombed
an historic monastery for nuns today?
Are you aware of this?
And you know who's reporting it? Quits.
Did you know that?
I got to be careful what I show.
So, right here,
an historic monastery
in southern Lebanon bombed by IDF.
Destroyed by IDF.
I've been busy today.
I've been seeing video after video, post
after post. It's right there, guys.
It's right there. You can click on the
link. I got to be careful what I show.
See right here?
I got to be careful.
Israeli occupation will demolish a stork
nuns monastery and school in town of
Yaroun, southern Lebanon.
Have you heard a peep
from Adulterous Prophet and Deborah
Goldstein?
You see why I'm saying glory to the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. Glory to
the Lord Jesus Christ.
Thank you, my brothers and sisters, for
your support.
You know why? Because I'm not trying to
manipulate you. The support
allows me to be free to speak my heart.
And you accept me warts and all and pray
for my sanctification.
So, thank you.
Do you know of any of the apologists
that are reporting this? Do you know of
any?
Can you show me who they are?
You let me show you something.
Here, you go to my profile, and boy, do
they get nasty there. Here it is.
Report after report. Can you do me a
favor? Can you go see Deborah Goldstein,
has he commented on this or
because I'm going to show you what
Adulterous Prophet said.
You want to see what he said?
I want to show you what Adulterous
Prophet said.
Easy solution. Don't people. But yes, he
shouldn't have been kicked. He should
have been shot.
All right?
Now,
I mistakenly thought
that he was saying this about
the nun who got beat.
But nonetheless, I told them what he is.
I reminded them of who he is.
So here when he said easy solution don't
people. Notice he's running quickly
to talk about these terrorists and
Hermits.
But can you go on a channel and tell me
if he's talked about the nun? Has
Deborah Goldstein talked about the nun?
Have they talked about the bombing of
this historic monastery by IDF?
All right. Note he's quick to talk about
Muslim terrorists
and their terrorism
and their people which you should
condemn.
We hate all evil.
I'm not Tucker Carlson who's going to
praise Sharia. God forbid. It's from the
pit of hell.
Right?
But guys, can you go to and see? Show
me. Maybe I'm wrong.
But they will do 50-hour sessions
attacking, defaming, decrying us and
send their dogs after us.
Now watch here.
Look at Look at all the things they're
doing that I can't show you cuz I don't
want to get flagged.
Because that video they said, "See? This
guy even posted it. I can't. This is the
guy who knocked her down violently."
Someone asked me, "How do you know
they're Israeli?" Because you dumb brain
ass, you see the fringes on their
clothes?
Zit zit. Only Orthodox Jewish men wear
that.
Do I need to explain that to you? So I
got to be careful. I got to be careful
what I show.
And how long will they
Christians? Here's the priest that they
in Lebanon.
The priest.
Here he is again. I got to be careful.
Now by the way, this one is going to
upset you.
Let me pause it.
This guy is standing outside a church,
spits at the church, and does the
crucifix with his two middle fingers.
Do you know that?
It's there on my YouTube. I'm sharing it
on my Twitter and there.
Do you know that, right?
This guy,
this Israeli,
goes before a church,
spits on the church, and does the sign
of the cross with his two middle
fingers.
It's right there. Go watch it. It's on
my YouTube and it's on Twitter.
See that?
YouTube and Twitter.
Now, here is a wonderful Jewish man
who spits out facts. Yossi Eli, maybe
Deborah Wollstein don't just probably do
a 50-hour video attacking him.
Tell
Calling it out for what it is.
A wonderful Jewish man
who's who's the voice of what he calls
Christian phobia.
The nun who belongs to the French
community in Israel, along with her
colleague and lecturer, sustained
non-trivial injuries and was evacuated
in mild condition. Footage from her
evacuation, right? The footage is simply
horrific.
Yep.
I can't play it. I don't want the They
say it's for, you know, Ever since I
started tweeting Look what he says about
Christianophobia.
A Jewish man
calling out his
fellow Jews.
I've been getting no small number of
utterly bizarre
whataboutism responses. Christians did
the Inquisition. What a delusion. Not
only that, I'm also getting
curses that I hate Israel, just like
someone told me. See? They can't refute
facts.
Israel's their god.
Reverend, give me a few minutes to rant.
The man who attacks a woman in cloth
just because she's from another faith is
a sick thinking racist.
And so are those who respond to him. If
a video like this came out of a
Christian brutally attacking a vis-
visibly religious Jew or a man of the
cloth, there isn't one person in the
state of Israel wouldn't be horrified.
This time, too, we must be horrified.
Yep, you see?
Okay?
Can you guys go on their channel? Go see
what it is. MORE DRAMA, DAWA DRAMA, and
Malik, and the central Dawa, and save
the drama for your mama, and Warren, and
and look, Sam is calling us That's it.
Nothing productive anymore. The dogs
have been heading over to their vomit.
That's it.
There he is. I don't I can't show you. I
don't want to get flagged. See? There's
this young lady. This is the lady.
They spit on her one time. Now, watch.
Cussing her out, spitting on her. Now,
watch.
They shouldn't flag this.
Okay. Look at here. Look at this man.
Look at this man.
See that? Slapped her.
Slapped her. Now, watch this.
Watch this.
Now, watch here. Look, look. Boom.
See that?
And she's crying.
Where is Deborah Woodstein and his
shekels?
Where is adulterous prophet?
Where?
Where, my brothers and sisters?
Where is the outcry for their brothers
and sisters in Christ?
When I tell you they're not Christian,
they're not. I mean, Apostle Prophet
clearly not a Christian. He's an
adulterer.
He committed adultery while still
married.
That's a fact. He can't deny it.
Can't deny it. And so, Deborah Woodstein
is platforming an adulterer.
And you really think they're Christian?
Seriously, where are their fruits, man?
Where are their fruits? So, this is why
I'm praising Jesus for you guys.
Pray my numbers do not drop. They stay
steady, in fact, increase of quality
people.
Because though our numbers are small,
you guys are sustaining this ministry in
a miraculous way cuz the Lord is working
through you. Now I can be free.
Do you appreciate, honestly, that I'm
being a voice for our brothers and
sisters of Jesus Christ being persecuted
by Zionists, by Israelis, by Jews?
As well as those non-Christians who are
being bombed?
I feel compelled to talk about it to
educate you.
So, we're not going to have thousands.
Quality over quantity.
All right?
All right. So, but you know this means,
right?
That's why I need you prayer warriors to
pray.
This is why I need you to pray cuz now
they're going to attack my character,
defame me,
try to bring out dirt on me, try to
remind you of my past, even though they
lied about a much of it,
and try to get me deplatformed and get
people to stop supporting me
financially. That's what they're going
to do.
Have they not done it to everyone?
Didn't Candace Owens, who I think is
kind of extreme, I'm not a Candace Owens
fan so I don't watch her.
I rarely watch her. I rarely watch
Tucker Carlson. God is my witness, he
knows if I'm lying.
But didn't they fire her from the Daily
Wire?
And I heard that Daily Wire what? Fired?
Had to let go what? 50% of their staff?
Which is a good sign, it means they're
losing money.
Yes, it is, brother. It's not blessed,
it's cursed.
Revelation 11:8, brother. You don't need
to ask me that. Here it is.
Do you want receipts? It's cursed. So,
now we're going to get into the topic.
Again, Lord Jesus bless you. Thank you.
I love you guys.
The support didn't drop.
As far as PayPal's concerned. Now pray
patron, it's the same. If it stays this
way, then I'll take that Lord will use
me to glorify the Lord boldly without
fear until I die until he returns.
Because sadly,
this does require money.
Right? I wish
I didn't have to worry about support and
not even have you guys support on PayPal
patron.
But it is what it is. If God has called
me to ministry,
I didn't receive an inheritance where my
rich dad like Bruce Wayne was left
millions. Then I would not take a single
penny.